[Music]
[ __ ] go jump in the morning to you
laddies I just got back from intensive
and no they didn't give me laughing gas
gonna be bunching notebook King and my
whole mouth is numb I can't feel like I
have real anything at all
so I'm off sick told you it's a whole
smorgasbord of dilemma didn't my face
break no anyway we today are gonna try
to get out the twelve days of Christmas
and then I unfortunately everybody in
the room is also sick I have been
seconded everybody it feels like my lips
are completely swollen but they're gone
are they
[Music]
as soon as Tyler get to Rack we're gonna
record we'll get this you better grab it
and everything in English pain the
universe is a cruel mistress
we'll just enjoy the company of others
so as we wallow in sorrow after all a
trainee cube we will find that the
vacuous void we're gonna feel my hairs
but not the skin under it you comes that
sketch
[Music]
oh he's doing it again
Tyler what he's doing it again oh no
stop it
I thought we warned you the first time
they're telling Jim except the choirs
dad no no wait wait we can't do this
again we can't do the exact same thing
we've done again everybody go over the
top on this one okay it's gotta be good
no Tyler what are you doing here I
thought we told you for tonight
they're not together no we can't do this
again we can't do this again we've got
to sell this like man what Ben Big Ben
Big Ben I remember Ben I am special yes
I am yes I am very special
I am very special yes
[Applause]
[Laughter]
here we go Katherine you need to you
need to film better so this is funny no
no no he's doing it again you're doing
it again we'll settle this like real men
stop everything down
no confused and aroused there's got to
be one drop of comedy somewhere no he's
doing it again
just doing it again no we talked about
it alright
oh we got plenty of them no no boy my
that dirty mind outta ya we we can
settle this we can settle this like men
put everything down
[Music]
we're drained all funny out of it we had
a good time guys we had fun and that's
all it matters right right hi I'm back
now
aye aye I'm better than I was because
most of my face is back under my control
except my bottom lip which is still numb
I wanted to say because they didn't say
before because I was totally out of my
mind that the 12 days of Christmas is
still gonna be happening we're still
gonna be getting them out but it's going
to be delayed we're working very hard on
it right now as you can see right here
we've got this exclusive listen
[Music]
[Laughter]
but uh thank you um where's it going is
it at the end it's conscious
[Music]